[Music]
all right so this is session 19 of
philosophers in the midst of history we
missed one due to my having covid in in
may
uh which was no fun but you know better
now we skipped over bonaventure
who um would have been cool to cover
great franciscan philosopher and i was
thinking actually on the the drive up
here so we're going to talk about this
guy georg wilhelm friedrich hagel and
i'm just going to call him hegel from
from this point on so i don't have to
like say all those
names or just the letters that we
usually
go by um but you know so we've been
doing this series now since 2016
and we've covered a lot of different
people from
ancient philosophy and medieval
philosophy and
um 19th century modern philosophy and
then 19th and 20th century philosophy
and so
i thought um
you know hegel himself
made it his
task to try to engage with everybody who
had come before him
and
he also winds up being influential for
better for worse on a lot of people
after him many of whom we've talked
about before so we talked about you know
plato and aristotle he thought they were
very important he actually likes
aristotle quite a lot
um we talked about you know early modern
philosophers like hobbs and
and descartes hegel is incorporating
them and we've talked about later
philosophers like
simone de bevoir for example or hannah
rent who talk about hegel and there's
even um people who react pretty strongly
against hegel like friedrich nietzsche
that we've done
and
you know in a certain way you if you're
reacting against somebody you're still
influenced by them right you're not
fully getting away from them and so you
could say that hegel is
kind of connected with almost all the
people that we've talked about except
the ones that he doesn't appreciate like
you know we talked about thomas aquinas
hegel doesn't like him much you know
um and that has to do with like sort of
lutheran catholic polemics and stuff
like that
um
he doesn't really know much about anselm
who we've talked about
but most of the others he's you know he
really put in the time and work
whether he got them right or not what
we'll talk about so this session
will focus on hegel the whole series is
focused on understanding philosophers in
relation to history so we'll talk a bit
about um the history before hegel and
his own life and what was going on turns
out he lived in
you know you know all know that proverb
may you you know not live in interesting
times he was living in interesting times
just as we are today
and we'll talk about the history that he
um
influenced and his own views
on history because one of the things
that's it's not unique to hegel but it's
certainly
an important contribution that he's
making
he wants to bring history into
philosophy so as opposed to just doing a
history of philosophy right where we say
well you know first there was these
pre-socratic people and there were
socrates and then plato was his student
and few other students but we're going
to leave them aside and then aristotle
and then these other instead of just
doing that he is saying human
development
has to be understood through philosophy
and philosophy conversely
through human development so like
plato and aristotle or rene descartes or
or other people
in some respect
could not possibly have been as advanced
in their thinking
as hegel was or even his immediate
predecessors
according to hegel
there's so much to say about this we
were just actually chatting before
uh this about like the possibility of
boning up on on hegel and with some
philosophers you could kind of do that
you go to the wikipedia article or
something like rene descartes right um
you could you're not going to get
everything by looking at a few sources
but you can kind of get the main gist of
it
so
actually let me ask you so
what was your impression in trying to
uh
get a thumbnail sketch of this guy
i don't think there is a thumbnail
sketch
he was reading it to me during lunch
okay
well you know i think there are but
they're all wrong
and why is that well it's because this
there's a number of reasons one one is
as we're also talking about before that
hegel he's he's got a lot of as we say
irons in the fire he's also not a great
clear writer like some of his
contemporaries if you ever read his
stuff
it's pretty muddy and figuring out what
the hell he's saying is is often a
significant task too so that leads to a
lot of different interpretations so when
you go to like well what's what's the
standard take on hegel there really
isn't any right because it's all over
the proverbial
map
so i would like to actually begin with
with two things one that i often do
in these talks which is to say why i
wanted to bring in this person and
how i got into them a bit but the other
is to
something kind of new
i think it's good to address what we can
call hegel myths
thumbnail sketches that turn out to be
wrong that people make a lot of use out
of
so my own interest and involvement in
hegel um
as an undergraduate
uh i i read a little bit of it didn't
understand any of it and my professors
would have you know more or less
dissuaded me from reading hegel they
thought he wasn't that important because
he got most things wrong
and he was mostly interesting because of
the criticisms that people had of him
and one of my teachers who was actually
a german guy who had lived as a child
through world war ii said that when he
needed to get to sleep he would get out
hegel and start reading it because he
found it so boring that it was a
soporific
so that was not a great start
and but i knew that he was kind of
important because a lot of other people
kept talking about him like you know
john paul sartre simone bouvoir or uh
camus or the people that i was really
interested in and then i got to grad
school and i found out that people
thought hegel was a big deal you know it
was quite important the analytic
philosophers didn't care much about
hegel uh but the continental
philosophers were like this you you know
you've got to read this book this this
particular version the phenomenology of
spirit because a lot of 20th century
french and german philosophy is drawing
upon that pretty pretty heavily
and it also feeds into american
philosophy which is something else that
they they specialized in
at southern illinois university where i
went so i started reading hegel and we
actually had a
graduate level seminar use this
book not this particular copy this is
this is the one that i
use and it's gotten kind of beaten up
over the years but we had a graduate
level class taught by a professor who
was very interested in hegel but who was
not a hegelian and so that's almost kind
of better right where you're getting a
take that's not
a true believer you know
and then
the students thought that hegel was so
important and interesting that we
actually organized a year-long hegel
reading group to go back through the
entire phenomenology
bit by bit by bit and so that was a kind
of a cool thing that we did
um i think you know we probably got a
lot of it wrong but
we we did that and i liked hagel so much
that i i considered writing my
dissertation on him
um
and then you know that's kind of a big
investment a dissertation is a book
and uh so i i formulated at first i was
just going to write on hegel
and then i was
going to write on hegel and a guy who's
often called the catholic hegel or the
french hegel maurice blondel who we'll
be talking about in the fall
we'll be going over his life he's a
later
uh thinker
and um then my committee actually ended
up saying why don't you just focus on
blondel you know you're hegel and blown
down too much
uh you're not gonna actually get this
done just you know everybody's working
on hegel why don't you work on this
other guy instead and one of the things
they had to do
back then they had these examinations
they don't have these anymore in most
schools
but they had these what they call
preliminary examination so before you
get to work on your phd before you get
to like write out what your project is
going to be
you got to take you got to sit down and
you've been like studying for an entire
semester cramming your head full of all
sorts of stuff so that you can
regurgitate it on paper answering
questions that you don't know in advance
in essay form
and one of the
four exams that we had to take was
called a special thinker exam
and your special thinker you know if
you're like working on descartes well
he's your special thinker and then they
would say read all these things and be
ready to answer these questions
so the guy who had given that class he
was in charge of the committee and i
said well what should i do i'll do hegel
what should i do he said well you know
just memorize all of the dialectical
developments in the phenomenology
and so i actually made this gigantic
chart for myself
uh as i went through it you know for
like the third or fourth time uh you
know in very small things like putting
together the whole system as i
understood it and then you know
again tried to cram that as much as i
could in my head a lot easier to do when
you're younger in your 20s than than now
i don't think i could do it and then he
said i said is there anything else and
he said yeah you know just some bits and
pieces of the science of logic too which
is you know a book that's like you put
the volumes together it's like this
thick
just the main points right and i i'm
sure that there was a lot of stuff i
left out but it was kind of cool because
it it gave me the opportunity to take a
complicated system in which there's all
these different parts connected to each
other
and try to make sense of it
you know which is a valuable
activity i will mention one other thing
too there was they had a second edition
in the german of hegel's phenomenology
in the southern illinois university
carbondale
library in the old german script and i
took it out of the library when we had
that class and i could i could actually
read that script because when i learned
german
it just so happens i learned it from an
older textbook pre-war and so i could
read the frock tour and so i
i made a bad decision in retrospect
back then if you lost a library book
they would charge you 55 bucks so they
could replace it whatever it was whether
the book cost 10 dollars whether the
book cost 150
they would charge you that flat rate
and i thought to myself i i really would
like to keep this book you know
and i don't know that anyone else would
really appreciate it
um
so maybe i should steal it that way and
just tell them i lost it right and then
i thought to myself and here's where my
reasoning process i think went wrong
i said
oh that's not good you shouldn't steal
things
i'll take it to special collections and
give it to them and say i'm tempted to
take this i'm sure somebody else would
take this off the shelves so i went into
special collections you know all
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed and i was
like look at this amazing book that
you've got in the library and they
looked at it the guy opened and he's
like this is a second edition we don't
care about this crap you know um
you do whatever you want with it and i i
didn't
keep it and
take it you know
and i still kick myself today because i
remember seeing the library just
throwing out like entire dumpsters of
books
right that nobody else was checking out
and i thought
i bet it wound up in one of those it's
not something they they would have kept
and a second addition you know
um
it's a kind of kind of a
tricky thing to think about should i
have stolen it shouldn't i have stolen
it you know on the one hand stealing is
wrong
on the other hand
special book you know
um now the other thing that i want to
talk about before this is hegel myths
so
one of the when i'm when i say myths
what i mean are like mistaken ideas
about this guy hegel which you might get
in
you know reading um
summaries or stuff like that or in
popular culture because
in our current culture wars hegel has
been believe it or not
brought into them
um sometimes on the side of people on
the left more often on by people on the
side of the right who are complaining
about postmodernism or critical race
theory or stuff like that and claiming
that somehow hegelian dialectics is
involved in it so that's the first myth
to start with
hegel is often portrayed as
having this dialectical method where
you've got a thesis which is the first
starting point and then you have
an antithesis
right so the ante against opposed to it
right and then you put those two
together and you come up with a higher
synthesis and that history works this
way and thinking works this way and
hegel actually doesn't say that
as a matter of fact the word synthesis
comes up in in the phenomenology
only a few times and mostly as an
adjective synthetic rather than as
synthesis and antithesis um does come up
a lot in this translation
but a lot of times it doesn't mean
actual antithesis it means something
like contradiction or opposition and
hegel didn't think that things proceeded
in this neat you know triadic first you
got a thesis then something else comes
about that that resists it and then you
put the two together and you wind up
with something you know wonderful and
new he didn't think that at all
this is what people said that he thought
um but it's a misrepresentation
of his
approach which is much more complicated
and you know as usual there's a history
to this so there was this guy
heinrich
who is giving lectures on post
conscience philosophy and we'll talk
about kant in just a minute
um
and he was giving these in 1835 and 1836
and then these lectures were published
in 1837
he attributed this to hegel
and that kind of gets the ball rolling
and then a lot of other people
will pick up on that so for example karl
marx and friedrich ingalls will
attribute something like this to hegel
and they'll say we're just going to do
it better right so in dialectical
materialism
you will see references to dialectics of
course and to this you know here's the
thesis here's the antithesis here's the
synthesis and then you
move on
um
alexander kojev who we'll talk about a
little bit later
he was a very influential
hegel popularizer and interpreter
who by the way walked the walk um he
ended up working for
uh what eventually became the eu the
european union as a bureaucrat because
he thought that's where world spirit was
headed you know so you know you got to
admire somebody who actually you know
puts their stuff into practice that way
um somebody else who i think is a
particularly
not a villain but a
a careless sloppy
writer in this respect who also
perpetuates the thesis antithesis
synthesis thing william durant if you've
ever read the story of philosophy which
is a perennial best seller you can find
it in any bookstore
he attributes this to hegel
and because of that i think a lot of
other people bought into that and you'll
see you know
people
bringing it up martin luther king
actually references
hegel
clearly hasn't like studied hegel
closely because he buys into this thesis
antithesis
synthesis and it goes all the way down
to the present to people who are you
know against what they take to be
critical race theory and they they claim
that the left is using hegelian
dialectics to arrive at this and it's
all like
basically made up stuff on their part
but they'll invoke this
thesis antithesis synthesis thing
because it's such a evocative myth i
mean it helps you
again hegel is hard to understand
wouldn't it be nice if there was like
one key that you put in the lock and
then it all makes sense and that that's
what they've been doing with it
another hegel myth
which does come out of the phenomenology
of spirit
is
that hegel is primarily his key idea is
the master slave dialectic right
and the idea of the master slave
dialectic just put very quickly
is that you've got consciousnesses early
in history and they come together
and they're you know they're fighting
with each other for recognition and one
of them gives in because it doesn't want
to die the other one is willing to risk
death and we have an aristocracy
established you know power structures
where the strong
become the master the ones who give in
become the slaves and you know it looks
pretty bad for them right but then
there's a trick because the slave
is put to work on things
you make the slave do the things you
want so you don't have to do them right
so if you don't like fishing you get the
slave to do the fishing and then they
clean the fish then they cook the fish
and then you know you just sit back and
enjoy the fish or pick whatever else you
want somebody needs to give a massage
um somebody needs to get a massage the
master is going to get the massage the
slave's going to be giving the massage
right and no no massages for the slaves
unless they give them to each other we
could go on and on and on
now as the as the master is is doing
that they enjoy they get recognition
they get you know
satisfaction but they don't develop
the slave being put to work is where
consciousness develops because they have
to deal with you know objects that that
resist them that don't give them what
they want right away
and
because of that
they become smarter they become more
sophisticated and
eventually they are the ones who are
connected to reality and the master
becomes disconnected from reality now
that's that's
that's in here
so that's not you know
false like the thesis antithesis
synthesis thing right but
it is
about
this amount of the book
see a little sliver
so now you know some of this book is
actually notes and stuff like that so
the actual
text goes to
about here
um so there's way more notes than there
are master slave dialectic um but you
know it gives you an idea about how how
central how important this is a lot of
people have acted as if like this is the
main idea that hegel has to give us it's
definitely not there's some really
important stuff being brought up there
but it's it's very early on in the
development and you could say that part
of the rest of the book is about how do
we get past that
so that we're not just in
these antagonistic power relationships
so we can have
what hegel calls recognition onair
kenong or acknowledgement which is
something that hegel thinks we all
fundamentally want from other people
we're looking for
when we say i feel seen that that's
recognition
you know
so that's you know that's one that's off
another thing you might see hegel
described as an idealist and when we say
the word idealist there's there's
basically two ways that people
interpret that in our contemporary
culture one is to say oh you're an
idealist you have you know all these uh
optimistic
notions about human beings so
um
you're you know you're disengaged from
the messy realities that we're in and
closely connected to that is an older
idea idealism as a philosophical
doctrine is saying that consciousness
essentially
pervades everything
or potentially does
right
things exist for
minds and it could be like you and me
human minds it could be
world spirit as it is for hegel could be
god in a traditional sense or something
like that
um but there's nothing that is just like
independent out there
by itself because even to conceive that
you're thinking of it right so that's
still an idea
um
now hegel yes he is an idealist but
there's more to idealism than that
hegel's favorite word that you see over
and over again is verclick or virkliq
and that means actuality or reality
and so there's this constant interplay
between having an idea
like you know let's say you know human
beings should be free to decide their
own destinies
would you all agree with that it sounds
pretty good right what does that
actually look like
in reality when we actualize it when we
put it into practice well should we let
everybody do whatever they want what if
my destiny is to be a serial killer you
know we say oh no no we didn't mean that
kind of destiny we didn't mean that kind
of freedom now we're actually getting
down to
you know the what we call the nitty
gritty the messy stuff and every idea
this is typical hegel
you figure out what the idea means
when it's not just words by trying to
translate it into reality and we can do
this with historical things like the
french revolution which was about
let's take a slogan right liberty
uh
freedom and brotherhood
sounds really nice doesn't it you know
liberty freedom everybody should be able
to do what they want yeah but not
everything
equality yes but does that mean like
doctors should get paid exactly the same
thing as the janitor maybe not right we
we get into the the
concrete realities of things and it
starts to get a lot trickier but that's
that's where we see what an idea really
means
you know
when somebody says i love you hey
anybody can say i love you or write a
card or you know send you a text
what does it look like in real practice
well it means you know sometimes
picking somebody up at the airport or
you know
figuring out when they're down and
rubbing their shoulder or something like
that that's vehicle or actuality so
idealism doesn't have to mean like just
living in this kind of
fantasy castle of the mind off
somewhere
another thing that's perhaps uh less i
mean those are all kind of theoretical
something else that's a bit more
concrete hegel gets um tarred
as being the father of totalitarianism
in the 20th century
because he did write about politics and
he did have an idea that the state
the political community should be this
comprehensive thing that includes
everybody and we find our freedom within
it so some people are like yeah hegel
leads directly to you know through marx
to communism
uh the worst abuses of it you know
whether it's uh russian or chinese or
cambodian or pick whatever you like
or to
fascism and nazism and now there were
some people who were invoking hegel for
that sort of thing hegel himself would
not have
agreed to any of that as a matter of
fact he's often presented as being
sort of the philosopher of the prussian
state
which
you know
in the 19th century was
quite powerful and was getting more and
more
extensive over time but he also
disagreed with quite a few of the things
that the prussian state itself was doing
so he wouldn't have been
um if you know if you brought hegel into
the 20th century and you're like see
what you did he'd have been like i
didn't do that you know i don't know
where the hell this stuff came from but
it's not coming from from me any more
than like nazism is attributable to
uh nietzsche you know uh who who
rails against pan-germanism and
anti-semitism or
things like that and then there's
finally one other myth so those are all
kind of negative things right hegel is
just doing this or hegel's bad because
of this
there's also
weirdly
some of you may have encountered stuff
like this with other texts
there is this tendency to say
with this text in particular the
phenomenology of spirit
we have the key to unlock everything
within the universe and he figured out
everything if you resist hegel he sucks
you back into the dialectic
and that's not true i mean hegel has
lots of gaps there's lots of things i
mean this is written and published in
1807 that obviously the translation is
newer than that and this book is newer
than that but
he hadn't figured everything out
the future yet to come
i mean it would take him a while to
adapt to figuring out what our mobile
technology is doing not to say that he
he couldn't because he's a smart guy but
um
he is not the one thinker that has
everything figured out any more than
benedict spinoza which sometimes people
like to do
with that is or other more recent
thinkers i think that there's some
people who
it's kind of like a philosophical
fundamentalism you know where they find
somebody and they're like within their
their single text or the body of their
work
everything is dealt with i just have to
find the answer somewhere you know
i've got a problem well here we go
paragraph 452 this universe universality
which the individual such attains is
pure being death it is a state which has
been reached immediately in the course
of nature not as a result of an action
consciously done and you're like oh
there we go that that resolves it i just
got to figure out
how this actually translates to whatever
it is that i'm interested in but you
know the answer must be there somewhere
and i don't think that's really the case
um so we can call that a hagel myth as
well right a more positive myth
hegel figured everything out as opposed
to hegel as the you know origin of
critical race theory and bad because of
that or hegel you know created
totalitarianism or any of these other
things and and you could say you know
i didn't actually think about this
before but
it says something about a person that
there can be these
plausible enduring myths about them
right
there must be something there
because you wouldn't make up this stuff
about somebody who was just
you know third rate
and didn't have anything to offer so
so that's a good uh way to jump in and
we'll we'll talk about um
history a bit more now and i gave you a
um a timeline that tells you about some
of the key things
in his life on one side is like you know
what what's happening to hegel what is
hegel doing on the other side the bigger
history that he's involved in which
mostly you'll notice has to do with
bless you with germany or the
german-speaking world
and with france
i mean there's a little bit of reference
to england in there
or to russia here and there but um hegel
himself is living
within um
germany which which
up until that time there was still
actually a holy roman empire totally
dysfunctional could never get anything
done by that point
not paid an awful lot of attention to
but you got all these little german
states all over the place
each kind of doing their own thing
sometimes lining up with each other
sometimes not some of them more powerful
than others so prussia in the east is
rising
austria in the south
is going to be you know lining up with
with other
places and turning into a multinational
empire is austria-hungary but it's also
a german-speaking place
you've got bavaria which is one of the
largest of the western german states and
then you've got all these other
principalities and you know different
places and each of them has their own
rulers some of them have cities in which
there's universities they get to decide
the policies of that
and a lot of that is going to get
changed over the next you know
half century or so as germany coalesces
as a nation but this is before that
and so hegel is born in stuttgart
to his father gjorg and his mother maria
and early on he gets sent to school
first he gets sent to a german school
he's only three years old so you know
think about when we send kids to
preschool
this was not like
putting shapes into
boxes and crayons and you know drinking
some milk and having naps or stuff like
that this is actually like learning some
some stuff because
two years later they sent him to the
latin school and he already knows some
latin uh from from his his mom because
she was she was quite smart and then he
begins to attend gymnasium
and at the time that this is happening
you notice that like the american
revolution is happening over
in another continent gerda who hegel is
later going to meet comes to weimar
um
and becomes a minister of culture begins
to build up the university of yena where
hegel will later
be hegel meanwhile you know as a kid
goes to the gymnasium now the gymnasium
is um
you know you can think of it as like
middle school and high school put
together but there's a emphasis
on
um classical education
so he's he's reading a lot of stuff from
ancient greece and rome
um why you know just for antiquities
sake no because they think that this is
going to be useful reading homer can
actually give you some guidance about
what you ought to do or reading some
plato or reading aristotle
and then you know
the
war between
us america and the brits uh and france
also involved comes to an end you know
so there's a period of some peace this
by the way leaves france in even greater
debt than it had been before
uh which is part of what's going to lead
to the french revolution i mean there's
a lot of things that feed into that but
wasting money on uh playing geopolitics
turns out to be one of the drivers right
because then you got to raise taxes
right and the taxes in france this is a
bit of a digression
we're falling very heavily on the poor
and the middle class and the clergy
and the nobles would get you know they'd
get out of the taxes and so they weren't
paying their fair share
and the king was actually you know in
general trying to do right by the people
but
things were just so screwed up and so
dysfunctional that it didn't matter
his mother dies in 1784
1788 he graduates from the gymnasium and
he begins to study at tubingen
seminary and first he's studying
theology and then he decides ah i don't
really like theology that much i want to
study philosophy instead
and hegel was
not a great student
as a matter of fact
for those of us who are late bloomers in
life
or who you know kind of screw around and
squander our opportunities people like
hegel can sometimes be a consolation
because you can be like well you know
i mean he wasn't doing his important
writing until you know quite late in his
life
he wasn't always a good student he was
known for you know participating in like
drinking and
hanging out with with
girls and stuff like that
um
and he actually you know he had some
friends that were good good philosophers
and poets
but um
they also like to kind of you know kind
of enjoy themselves and among these are
um shelling
and huldurin
and they actually roomed together
in tubing and seminary they're all kind
of close with each other
and meanwhile as this is happening
we've got a lot of important things
taking place friedrich the great
of prussia who is not only a great
military commander and was you know
building up the prussian state but was
also in favor of of the enlightenment
he actually wrote a book called
anti-machiavelli you know as sort of
like his foray into philosophy he dies
and um
he left kind of an important legacy
emanuel kant is publishing the critique
of
pure reason and then practical reason uh
during this this time that hegel is in
gymnasium and
uh in in seminary and then the french
revolution takes place
and this is a major deal you know i mean
it affects
everyone across europe
um in part because you know france was
one of the leading countries at the time
one of the most advanced countries
and um
they have this this revolution which
takes place in stages it's not like
everybody gets together and they're like
all right let's let's fix things uh
instead it's at first they storm the
bastille
and then they're like okay what next and
there's a whole bunch of what next
all sorts of crazy proposals get put
into to play sometimes actually practice
like you know let's put everything on on
the decimal system
10 you know 10 day weeks
10 months of the year you know maybe we
can even like get rid of the 12 hours uh
and and you know 60 seconds and stuff
like that 60 minutes let's make
everything tens you know why well it's
more rational you know some of these
things didn't stick
with the metric system uh you know
measuring things in meters um
that's that's hung around
um other things along those lines all
sorts of proposals for like how should
we change society how should we make it
more fair
and
they didn't all agree with each other
they form first a national assembly and
then they're going to have some power
grabs going on
over time
and in the meanwhile um when this
happens in france the other
major kingdoms
are looking around and they're like
oh this is bad you know what if that
happens here we got to put an end to
this and so the other countries within
europe many of them start forming
coalitions and there's a series of
coalitions against revolutionary france
and major wars start start happening
in germany the key thing tends to be
france fighting against austria coming
up from the south very powerful and
prussia
and hegel himself um
is in favor of the revolution as are his
friends i mean they're young right and
it's happening at a distance they're not
so cool about the
the terror that happens
uh the reign of terror when people are
getting guillotined
by
you know the dozens
and sometimes hundreds or people are
being killed in other ways too i mean
some of you probably know about some of
the atrocities that took place within
france you know a popular way of killing
people was put them all on a boat and
sink the boat in the river and that's
the end of them you know that's how you
get rid of counter revolutionaries
there was a lot of stuff going on like
that but but hegel and his friends saw
this as
moving forward in history getting away
from
uh
kings and um religious figures and
bureaucracies that just stood in the way
of human beings fully developing
themselves
higgle was also a huge fan at that time
of jean-jacques rousseau
who is not not exactly an enlightenment
figure he's got a weird kind of tension
with the enlightenment but he did talk a
lot about politics and about how to
realize human nature and
things like that so france is is a um
fighting around the time that the reign
of terror is taking place and that the
king is being executed and kant is
publishing religion within the limits of
reason alone hegel receives a
theological certificate um which is you
know giving him
license essentially to um
to teach and he leaves
the
seminary
takes a position as a private tutor
and he's going to do this in two
different places now private tutor's a
good gig to get
it means that you are working for a
family for people who you know want
their kids educated hegel himself had
had some private tutorial as well when
he was younger
and then the rest of the time is
basically yours to do what you want with
you know you hang out with a family they
feed you they give you a place to stay
they give you some money on top of that
the family that he was staying with in
barron
he didn't like it there after a while in
part because they were they were on the
conservative side they
they were against the french revolution
and so things got to be kind of tense
after a while
and um so he goes to frankfurt and
becomes the tutor to a different family
um
meanwhile
somebody writes the oldest systematic
program of german idealism this is a
manuscript that was discovered
and it's in hegel's hand but we don't
know if he wrote it or not it might have
been shelling or it might have been
hoolered but it's it's you know a
early philosophical
document um what you see happening in
the world thing is napoleon is rising um
you know he's winning these military
victories eventually he's going to pull
off a coup
and make himself first consul
and then eventually emperor right and um
hegel meanwhile his father dies leaving
him an inheritance both to him and his
brother and his sister
and that allows that gives him some um
some flexibility you know he can now
uh he's not dependent solely on on
income that people are giving him
a little bit later in 1801 shelling
who's now well established helps him to
get a private dozen position at yana
which is a
at that time was considered like you
know cultural hotbed although it was
kind of on the way down and
this is a good position to have
but
you're not getting paid
as we would normally do like a salary
you're getting paid by
the number of students that you have so
if nobody takes your classes no money
right uh so you've got to get people to
to take your classes and and it does
work out for him
hegel and shelling also then is early in
his career found this critical journal
of philosophy but already there's
there's tensions between these
two philosophers
[Music]
then he's going to become an associate
professor at yena and that will give him
you know an income and some some
standing um now you notice in 1806
uh something uh interesting happens 1806
1807
there's a war going on and hegel is
working on the manuscript for this his
first great work right
there's a lot of stories told about this
you know oh it was composed well the
cannons were going off
that's probably not true right
but he did have to flee yana
with the manuscript not knowing whether
you know like somebody might stop him
and take it or something like that
in 1807 he does get it published
and
um
that's you know an important first step
for him and this is you know this is a
quite an important work
his views on it change over time
originally this is supposed to like
encompass everything and then it becomes
just part of his um
his system so to speak and actually let
me let me remark we'll take a little
digression so you notice i got all these
books on on the table
so there's different translations in
english this is one of the earlier
translations phenomenology of mind right
and you might say why is a phenomenology
spirit and phenomenology mind well it's
phenomenal phenomenology disguised
geist is translatable as spirit or
mind and so this one is is you know an
earlier
translation and it has different ways of
talking about stuff so instead of master
and slave it says lord and bondsman
right there's different ways to
translate the um
the german terms this has been kind of
the standard translation for quite a
while like when i was in graduate school
this is the one that you would get and
you would use for classes
in the last several years
three new translations have come out
not sure why
all this has happened this way but we've
got this uh phenomenology of spirit
translated by peter fuss and john
dobbins um university of notre dame 2019
right so just a few years ago
we have this this other one uh
published by
cambridge
terry pinkard which i particularly like
i've actually been using
his draft of it for a number of years
because he originally had it online and
then he took it down you know when it
came time to publish it because it had
his draft had the german on one side and
the english on the other so it was very
useful as i was doing work on hegel to
have the
german edition there and then we have
michael
inwoods
quite excellent
translation as well
this one 2018. so within the last four
years
we've had a number of other english
translations come out which one is the
standard translation none of them are
the standard translation now
right
so
it introduces a little bit of uh
we call it uncertainty to matters
going on with this hegel is going to
produce a number of other important
works
a science of logic which is published in
three volumes in different years later
on a somewhat easier work called the
encyclopedia uh
of the philosophical sciences sometimes
called the encyclopedia logic
he'll although he'll also publish
later on a
philosophy of right or spit you know
introduction to the philosophy of right
in 1820 and you notice that he's um he's
not churning out an awful lot of work
right
what we do have of hegel though a lot of
stuff so i've just brought one
book along with me besides those
um these are the lectures on the
philosophy of history and actually when
people there's a bit of a side note too
people are like i want to read hegel
where should i start and this is a
terrible place to start i've actually
created you know a whole series of
commentary videos on it but this is this
is actually not the best place to begin
this is one of the better places to
begin i always say start with the
philosophy the lectures on the
philosophy of history and the lectures
on the history of philosophy because
there he's giving you
a lot more
ideas about what he's doing it goes into
greater depth he names names in the
phenomenology half the time you got to
figure out who the hell he's talking
about you know so you need a lot of
background knowledge and he gives
lectures on a whole bunch of things
philosophy of religion
on law
lectures on aesthetics
right um
history as well
um
proofs on the proofs of the existence of
god is is another one that he goes into
and these are much more accessible i
think than than the the big works that
get published and these are compiled
from you know notes that he had and and
his students stuff as well
so meanwhile
what's happening on the the scene
i should mention you know he gets
married
i also should mention he had an
illegitimate child before he got married
who's going to die the same year that
that he is a son ludwig he
slept with his landlords wife
um and you know a child is is born
because of that winds up in an orphanage
eventually will join the hegel
family
and have kind of a troubled time he has
uh two sons with his wife maria
who survived there's also a daughter who
is born but dies
uh and then there was a stillborn child
as well or a miscarriage rather
and um you know his his domestic life
seemed to be quite good
he gets promoted you could say over and
over again in in different ways he goes
to berlin
succeeding
ficta who is a big german idealist
philosopher
very influential at the time eventually
gets elected university president
towards the end of his life
and
he's going to die there in berlin during
a cholera epidemic and the cause of
death is put down as cholera but
interestingly the hegel scholars the
people who do the biographies
quite a few of them are like nah he
didn't die of that he died of uh some
other things they look at the ailments
that he had been having before that so
it's sort of like with covid right do
people
did they die of covid did they die with
kovid you know what what's going on some
of the time we're not sure about the the
stats right now meanwhile uh what else
is happening so we talked a little bit
about the french revolution and napoleon
these massive wars going on that are
leading to the reorganization of you
know
universities and states and causing
displacements of people
germany gets assembled for a while into
something called the confederacy of the
rhine
a whole bunch of states get put together
in one political unit
bavaria is part of it but a whole bunch
of other ones
and from the hegelian perspective this
is pretty good right
from a lot of other people's
perspectives they weren't really for
that and napoleon as you all know goes
off to russia right in 1812
he's going to show the russians that
they need to follow his his economic
system
and
it
destroys his army you know a tiny
fragment of them make it back
and this leads to the german states um
revolting and the wars
of
national liberation happening in 1813
napoleon gets defeated in 1814 in a very
decisive way they send him off you know
to exile
um they weren't all that careful because
he escapes comes back in 1815
and uh that's the end of the napoleon
thing and then you know the rest of
europe is like what the well first of
all they put the bourbons back in charge
in france and they're like okay that's
enough of that revolutionary stuff
but what are we going to do now you know
the the continent has been kind of
fractured
all these ideas are loose in the air you
know and what we see happening in europe
is this back and forth between forces
that want to you know go back to how
things
were
and
more and more progressively
revolutionary
ideas and practices and you know this is
part of something that affected our area
not in hegel's time but
later on many of you know that germany
or that that um
milwaukee has this great german heritage
as does much of the midwest
and um a lot of the germans that came
came because of later revolutions and
they were on the losing side and they
were like we got to get the hell out of
here
um so they came to places like this
that's how we wound up with our
socialist heritage here in milwaukee
and you know other parts of wisconsin
it's one reason why we have more parks
per capita than many other
cities throughout the united states
you know they have this revolutionary
idea that poor people should be able to
like experience nature
and um you know so these things had
significant uh impacts
uh on on us hegel himself uh in this
this
you know he's he's okay uh towards the
end with a lot of these things because
he's mostly focused on
prussia berlin is in prussia and he's
focused on the prussian state and he
sees it as an opportunity
for having a you know sort of organic
society in which each of the classes
has its place a lot of his ideas that
are very you know early on very
progressive or liberal become much more
conservative towards the
end of his life um
not super conservative
um but you know
much more so he's and this is this has
to do with the translation of ideas into
reality you know how do you create a
state in which human beings can have
genuine freedom it's not going to be a
revolutionary state anymore it's not
going to develop into a terror where
people are being guillotined you know
one after another and the main guy in
charge of guillotining people ropes pier
is going to get guillotined himself
and then everyone will be like maybe we
should like you know come back to our
senses it's instead going to be an
established society in which everybody's
needs will be taken into account
everybody who's going to have their
place it kind of sucks if you're on the
lower side of it you know like let's say
you're a peasant
um but it there there were a lot of
opportunities for
um
you know participating within the
society hegel dies you know kind of i
mean is he that young i mean we think of
him as dying young he dies he's 61 years
old so maybe not that young right
um had plenty of time he's not like say
one of his critics or in kierkegaard who
dies i believe around
40 something or 50
some day even younger than that
so
that's the history that he's
involved in
we do question and answer i'd just like
to say a few things about his own
approach to history
um and then maybe we'll talk about his
his influence
we'll do some question answer then talk
about influence so i mentioned that
hegel took history seriously and thought
that we need to
bring it into philosophy as a way of
understanding things it's not like
earlier philosophers didn't do this
aristotle himself will talk about
progress that's been made from what he
calls ancient times to modern times
meaning his own time
for example he'll say that you know in
the past in in
tragedy
the
heroes talk like statesmen now they talk
like rhetoricians you know um and so
he's talking about how things are
changing or he'll talk about comedy he'd
be like older comedy was more about you
know
buffoonery and it was really kind of
silly we got the good stuff now you know
in new comedy
unfortunately we can't tell because we
don't have much of the new comedy left
but hegel thought that
human beings had developed
over time in all these different ways
in societies
and there are literally thoughts that
that i'm going to be kind of silly here
thoughts that couldn't be thunk back
then that can be
now and there's also correspondingly
ways that people approach things that we
can understand but we can't really apply
in our own present
a great example of this is in the
history of philosophy
he says this each philosophy
is a particular stage in the development
of the whole process and has its
definite place where it finds its true
value and significance its special
character is to be conceived of in
accordance with this and is to be
considered with respect to this position
in order that full justice may be done
to it on this account nothing more must
be demanded or expected from it than
what it actually gives
and he goes on he says we must not
expect to find the questions of our
consciousness and the interest of the
present world responded to by the
ancients
why not such questions presuppose a
certain development in thought so
aristotle's cool but aristotle can't
answer
the questions and problems and
conditions of
what hegel is calling modern for us you
know hegel's 200 years ago uh so offered
to yuri it applies to us as well and he
says every philosophy belongs to its own
time and is restricted by its own
limitations just because it is the
manifestation of a particular stage in
development
and he goes on and he says
every philosophy is the philosophy of
its own day a link in the whole chain of
spiritual development
on account of this an earlier philosophy
does not give satisfaction to the mind
which is in which a deeper conception
reigns what mind seeks for in philosophy
is this conception
which already constitutes an inward
determination and the root of its
existence uh conceived as an object of
thought mind demands a knowledge of
itself
and so the philosophy of plato and
aristotle and indeed all philosophies
ever live
and are present in their principles but
philosophy no longer has the particular
form an aspect possessed by that of
plato and aristotle we cannot rest
content with them and they cannot be
revived
today there can be no platonists
aristotelians stoics or epicureans to
reawaken them would be to try to bring
back to an earlier stage the mind of a
deeper color
culture and self-penetration but this
cannot be a case and he's got an analogy
here it would be an impossibility in as
great a folly as were a man to wish to
expend his energies in attaining the
standpoint of youth the youth
endeavoring to be the boy or child again
whereas the man the youth and the child
are all the same
individual so
you know i mean i might do things like
when we go shopping you know i might do
something youthful like
you know taking the cart back to the to
the
car you know i'll get a push the cart
and then get on the back and ride it
like a kid
but
you know
i can't live my life like that
i can do that on occasion and andy and i
can go to you know shows and see bands
that we loved from our youth and and
these bands you know some of the guys up
there playing are like 70 years old you
know
as a matter of fact one of the ones we
were looking forward to seeing he just
canceled the whole tour because you know
the singer's sick
and you know uh
probably lucky he's not dead at this
point right um given the way that he's
lived hegel is saying this about
philosophies he's saying we can't go
back in time even to stuff that we can't
we can't pick up rene descartes
and say we're going to be cartesians we
have to
figure out the philosophy for our own
time whether this is true or not you
know
that's debatable but hegel certainly
thought of things that way and why would
he
because he thinks that human
consciousness develops over time
now there's some good news bad news the
good news is is that you know if that's
true then things are getting better and
better and better the bad news is it's
not happening everywhere and the people
who were in the past
got left behind
uh hegel at one point calls history a
slaughter bench
right and wherever this development is
taking place it's only taking place in a
few spots
you know in hagel's time germany
and maybe a bit in france and a bit in
in
england and in america but it's not
happening in russia hegel says things
like
uh africa has no history i mean he he
sort of bought into the pseudoscientific
racism of the time
he also says though um
you know in this book about
history his history is that history is
the development of human freedom in
determinate ways within societies
but it doesn't happen everywhere
i mean where do you think it happens i
mean besides germany where else would
you say that it probably happens for
this guy
hegel any guesses
ancient greece and rome you know
what about you know what about these
great civilizations in asia
he re he talks about them
mostly you know
drawing on the ethnography and stuff of
his day he thinks he's gotta actually
get this formula that he says world
history is the record of the spirit's
efforts to attain knowledge of what it
is in itself
the asians do not know that the spirit
or man is such a free in themselves and
because they do not know that they are
not themselves free they only know that
one is free whoever happens to be in
charge right or perhaps you know the
philosopher like confucius or lao tza
the consciousness of freedom first awoke
among the greeks and they were
accordingly free
but like the romans they only knew that
some
not all people
are free
you know because they had slave
societies right
and then he goes on and he says the
germanic nations with the rise of
christianity were the first to realize
that all men are by nature free and that
the freedom of spirit is his very
essence
you know so long as they're protestants
because catholics they're not really
free either according to
hegel he was actually pretty pretty
hardcore anti-catholic there's there's a
story that's told about him in one of
the biographies where um he he made a
whole bunch of anti-catholic remarks and
um
in one of his his uh lectures and then
there was there were complaints to the
university
and his his response was basically
you know i'm a lutheran
and this is a lutheran uh
place
so
why would you come in here and expect
catholics to be treated you know fairly
or something like that
so it but it stems from his idea that
the protestant reformation was one of
these key turning points in history
where
and you know this does tie in with like
the opposite thing martin luther was
originally an augustinian monk right and
originally the protestants were not
trying to leave the catholic church they
were trying to reform it
they're saying there's some things going
on here that need to be fixed and there
were factions within the church some of
whom were like you better you know shut
up and and you know knuckle under that
was one faction there were others who
are like whoa there are some serious
problems and
we don't want to break everything up but
we need to fix these things and then
there were the the protestants who had
to leave right and so the lutherans were
among them um
[Music]
hegel did not really care much for other
protestants
he didn't like the fact that within the
prussian
state which was officially protestant
evangelicals not evangelicals of our day
but what were called evangelicals at the
time reformed and lutherans were kind of
mixing together he didn't think that was
cool but why because lutheranism
was the sort of development of of
human freedom in its most spiritual
sense
having to do with the highest things
relation to god religion and he thought
that that could be translated into
philosophy and that's that's basically
what's happening
by the end of this book the last big
section is religion
christianity winds up being the most
important of the religions
and then it leads to philosophy and you
take you take
religion and you kind of transform it
so there's a lot of
things going on with with history the
only other thing that i'll mention and
then let's do a little discussion in
q and a's
in this development as i mentioned not
everybody gets brought along
um
from the vantage point of a history
that's essentially finished and hegel
thought that history had more or less
worked itself out
we can look back and see all the cool
developments that have taken place and
be like oh that was important that was
important this led to a realization of
humanity
but um
most people in most cultures get left
behind
they and hegel says when the spirit
departs it doesn't come back
so if the spirit was there in ancient
greece
the contemporary greeks
ah there's nothing there
you know same thing with with uh rome
and italy
and so once it goes to germany well
that's where the real game is it's no
longer in england or france or places
like that
that seems very contestable you know why
why can't spirit go back to say spain
and you know
do something there hagel just thinks
that it doesn't
and he does think that history is
finished effectively
not that things don't happen
but the important transformations have
we've gone through them we've gone
through what he calls the shapes of
consciousness
i think if you brought him here to 2022
he'd probably
after you got through his culture shock
and learn to speak english
he probably would revise that
looking at the last couple centuries of
things that have happened
um
maybe history isn't quite so finished
off as he thinks but that that is what
he thinks and
part of the reason i think he was
attracted that idea is because there's
an epistemological issue
if you've got this super super
complicated dialectical process with all
these different moving parts that you've
got to keep track of
how do you know you're getting it right
how do you know that your
particular vantage point isn't just yet
one more thing that's going to be
surpassed and left behind in you know
the dustbin of history
well
if everything's finished that you don't
have that problem
if everything isn't finished then
maybe
you're just you know one more
perspective among many others which i
think is actually the case for hegel
you know that's part of why i'm not a
hegelian
so
that's so i've thrown a lot of stuff at
you and you probably have some questions
or you know reactions or things like
that i'll talk about the influence that
he had but let's let's pause for a
little bit about anything that's
confusing or you want to know more about
or
you know
what would you say the differences are
between the idea of the absolute spirit
and
monotheistic
oh that's so that's a great question so
monotheistic religion
figures into that right
absolute spirit i think of it like
containers so absolute spirit is the
biggest possible container and
everything's in it
but you don't know
most people
that it's absolute spirit you know the
thing that you're used to so like if we
think about monotheism
and it's it's development um so hegel in
in the phenomenology is going to talk
about it
in terms of first like uh judaism and
then christianity he actually doesn't
say much about he doesn't say anything
in the phenomenology really about islam
um he will in the lectures on the
philosophy of religion but he doesn't
seem to get too much of it
effectively right but what's happening
there so you've got like you know a move
to monotheism away from polytheism
and then um you've got you know the
heavenly father who you're connected to
and you've got a law and things like
that and then comes this jesus fellow
who um
[Music]
is you know
by by his followers effectively claimed
to be god incarnate and for higgle
that's really important
god comes down to us
becomes incarnate
teaches us
and what is he teaching us now here's
where it becomes less orthodox he's
teaching us that we're really god
now is that monotheism anymore not
really and this is where we're getting
to the absolute spirit and where are we
going to find this guy because it's not
like you're god and i'm god and he's
good and she's got cause then we just
got up another polytheism right
as a community
as connected with each other in in a
community that's not just antagonistic
but where we all find like true
recognition with each other
that is what god is
and it's kind of funny because hegel
insists on his you know orthodoxy hegel
was not orthodox at all
this is not standard lutheran stuff you
know so you got your monotheism and it
can take different shapes it's part of
this absolute um
spirit
understanding that um could take the
form of religion but could also be
understood as
philosophy it's not the kind of
philosophy that we usually talk about
right it's hegel's philosophy and it's
the thing that comes at the very end
and
i mean i have to say i don't find this
very attractive myself
um i i i like the stuff
more when hegel is getting down to the
nitty-gritty of a particular development
the whole like big big picture that i
think a lot of people are attracted to i
find
not just implausible but sometimes kind
of repugnant um
i don't want to be part of that absolute
and i think that's where a lot of
reactions against hegel by the
existentialists
came about so does that help yeah okay
is there this distinction to be drawn
between heidegger's being oh
and and and the absolute so that's
that's an interesting i would say yes
so martin heidegger
thinks that hegel is a really important
uh metaphysician
and heidegger also has this kind of
developmental view right but hegel's
part of it and he actually says that
nietzsche is the last great
metaphysician after hegel and of course
hegel doesn't know nietzsche right
and what he thought that was really
important about hegel is that hegel
um
brought history into metaphysics
you know
so you know hyder has a history of
metaphysics and then we become kind of
conscious of being involved in that with
with hegel
heidegger um
his fundamental metaphysics there's
being with a capital b right and that's
everything and even the the things that
we don't
know about and then there are beings
right and we are a weird kind of being
uh that he calls dozen
that is able to
ask questions about being and could even
have like in his later stuff he talks
about us as being like caretakers of
being or you know stewards or stuff like
that
but the the big be being is always
something that like totally exceeds us
it's not god because even god is just
like a
conception of of being and throughout
history we've had um different ways of
taking a
kind of lowercase b being
and blowing it up into
uppercase b being so like for plato was
the forms right in the form of the good
for um
hegel it's
spirit
um but that's still only a partial
viewpoint so heidegger thinks that that
hegel
like everybody every other great thinker
or perspective through history has
gotten some things right and then where
they got things wrong took us on to a
wrong track
um
and and that would have to do with like
where are we going in our own history
you know like if you believe that
hegel's got things right this is where
we can talk about like his successors
what do you do with this stuff right
but if you think that he's got things
wrong then maybe you don't have that
worry
or or if you think he's got things
partly right and partly wrong then you
can kind of try to fix
bits of it you know
so they're so they're doing similar
things but it's there's not a
coincidence between what they're what
they're um putting out there is like the
absolute
you know i mean heidegger doesn't say
being as the absolute because
the absolute is like something else that
that
fits into being you you know when i was
saying at the absolute is the bucket
being is a yet bigger bucket
you know this is something that
philosophers often do to each other
they're like
you think that you've got your finger on
the pulse of what's absolutely most
universal well i'll do you one better
and the german idealist did this with
their absolutes too and they all talked
about the absolute right
but some people's absolutes are more
absolute than others
so to speak
it eventually becomes you know kind of a
a bragging contest doesn't it
so
i kind of feel it is
go ahead
i'll try
sure
so
you talked about exploring the myths
yeah yeah
dialectics he doesn't use dialect no he
does he does but he's just not using the
terms is that
no no he's he's doing something
dialectical but his dialectics are more
complicated
than the thesis antithesis synthesis
thing yeah
and and you know there's other terms
that um get used a lot more
by him
i mean it very often is the case that
like something will generate its
opposite so you know the thesis
antithesis thing
can happen although he doesn't say first
we have the thesis then we have the
antithesis like
um
contradictions and characters yeah yeah
and so actually
this is another thing i should have
mentioned earlier um this is part of the
problem with hegel it's like there's so
many different parts that you're like oh
yeah there's also this that we should
bring in
so when we think about contradiction we
usually think about it like in terms of
there's a contradiction here one of
these things must be true and then the
other one i'm going to throw away or
maybe both of them are false and we look
at it in kind of a static way right for
hegel contradictions can be dynamic if
there's a development that's going on
there so
one thing will you know
produce its opposite as sort of a
counter response to it
and then
that will
bring about a and there's a couple
different terms used gagen zots which we
translate typically as
contradiction and gagan uh gazettes
which literally like things are being
set in opposition to each other
i'm blanking on the other term that he
uses much more which is kind of in the
middle
and what we have to do is observe well
how are these contradictions
worked through
i mean the usual way it's translated is
reconciled um but i think working
through
is a sometimes a better translation so
if you think about like interpersonal
dynamics now hegel doesn't really talk
about interpersonal psychology or
anything like that but people do use him
and dialectics in that
and so you know you've got like uh
a kid and their parents and they're not
getting along what's what's happening
here well the kid is rebelling and the
parent is clamping down and now we've
got a situation of contradiction
um you know can they work through it or
are they going to be in conflict forever
you know
um maybe they will be in conflict
forever but
it could be possible to move past that
and to you know raise the relationship
up to
a better level where both people are
getting acknowledged they're not always
totally happy with how things work but
that would be what hegel calls
auf heibong
which we often translate as
transcendence or sublation or things
like that and that means taking the the
things that we're working with and
bringing them into i mean if you want to
call it a synthesis you could but it's
not really a synthesis as such it's more
like taking the essential things and
then leaving all the crap all the
inessential stuff behind
and attaining something better and you
know at least in this work it's it's so
much well and also i would say in the
philosophy of right it's so much driven
by
our desire for
being acknowledged recognized by other
people being treated as if we're fully
human you know
no is this can this be a loop though in
other words oh
yeah yeah you look at it closer and you
see new outfits yes
yeah that happens and then you kind of
go and yeah
he goes wrong around around in the goal
that he to the uh the absolute yeah
and he now you're from what you were
seeing did you think it was actually at
the absolute back
it was it was like
we we just got to like cross the t's and
dot the eyes kind of stuff
yeah
no so that's that that's that's a really
great segue
where do we go after hegel right there
were these people called the right
hegelians after hegel dies and they
basically had that idea that you know
everything's more or less been worked
out
the state's not working exactly as it
should but we can fix that we can
harmonize things a bit but the the broad
outlines are fixed right and finished
and then there were the left hegelians
and you know the most famous of which we
know of is is karl marx but there are
these other people like ludwig feuerbach
and um actually david strauss is is an
early one he writes this life of jesus
in which he's applying this to biblical
representations of of jesus and uh and
bruno bauer is doing similar things as
well
um ludwig feuerbach is going to advocate
for a religion of humanity you know so
they're all kind of like as we say
pushing the envelope right and these
younger they're sometimes called the
young hegelians or the left-handed
aliens they're all like
well hegel didn't get everything right
as a matter of fact he left out
important things that now we're going to
bring back in like marks with saying i'm
going to turn hegel on his head you know
he didn't look at the economic
substructures of things and those
developments
and there's a certain kind of truth to
like saying yes hegel's missing some
stuff i mean
you look at some of the things that they
develop and you're like well this is
this has got some gaps too
or some single single emphasis and then
there's other people who don't
fit quite as neatly into that left and
right thing like there's this guy mock
sterner who's a
an egoist and kind of prefigures
nietzsche in certain ways but uses
hegelian terminology and ideas right
hegel became so influential
that even if you were opposing him
like sir and kierkegaard did
you would use um a lot of his concepts
and terminology
you know
stuff that we don't really relate to as
well in philosophy today
but you know that language made its way
into things sometimes you know
not always for good i would say
there were other um
ways in which hegel
became very influential there were like
hegelians all over the place so he
caught on in russia
in around the 1840s um
italy there were hegelians there a whole
bunch of british um
good evening
we always get this
if you need a library card
sure enough
also be aware that internet computers
will be turned off shortly thank you and
have a great evening all right
so um a lot of british idealists right
um he caught on in france there's a guy
victor kuznet who visits hagel during
his lifetime and then like brings
hegelian ideas there but then others
are are doing it as well and there was
there was even an interesting american
connection that i wanted to mention so
the you know we talked about the
transcendentalists
um you know emerson and thoreau and
those people it was actually a very big
movement
and
emerson and thoreau aren't really like
you know responding much to hegel
they're and they're getting their german
idealism primarily through
coleridge
in england who who writes about um
kant and victon shelling
um
but other transcendentalists were
influenced by hegel and then there was
actually a whole school called the saint
louis hegelians
they were doing projects like
trying to understand the american civil
war by applying hegel's ideas to
freedom right you know it's
fundamentally about the
development of human freedom in concrete
ways you know why is the north able to
bring so much economic muscle to bear on
this uh you know kind of left behind
culture of the south they were they were
applying hegel to that
um there were other people like josiah
royce who were quite influenced by hegel
and were idealists and
so that was quite important and then
in the 20th century um you know i'll
mention too so the phenomenology was not
really like the most important work by
hegel
in his lifetime and in
the 19th century a lot of people are
more engaging with his
encyclopedia logic or the philosophy of
right or you know more mature works you
could say
in the 20th century this becomes like
the big book and it's in part because
the um
the frenchies really get into it
it's it's attributable and part
attributable in part to this guy
alexander kojev
who was a very charismatic
thinker and was interpreting hegel in
paris and had all these people taking
essentially seminars with him
you know big names
like um
you know maurice merlo ponti
and jacques laca
raymond aaron you know
george battai
even
somebody else who's going to be the
translator of hegel in the french
of the phenomenology at least johnny
pelitt who's going to write a great
commentary as well
and they're
really focusing not just on this but on
that portion of it we call the master
slave dialectic they're taking that as
sort of the central
hermeneutic
so hegel is going to play a big role but
one of the things you can always say is
like well what does your hegel look like
what are the things that you're focusing
on you know what are the things that you
take as being really essential like is
it is it the absolute because if it's
that i'm not quite so into it you know
is it the master slave dialectic that's
kind of cool but it's you know it's kind
of limited in its scope is it
the remarks about
you know how each ethical project that
we try always reveals that it's way more
complicated than the easy system that we
start with that i'm attracted to that's
kind of cool you know and that that you
can find a lot of in here and in like
the philosophy of right so you know
in a way hegel is like socrates
um
which socrates are we
talking about right and so the you know
the right hegelians they have one hegel
the left hegelians have like
half a dozen hegel's all these other
people have different hegels that
they're making out of things
many of them don't appear to have been
very close readers
of hegel when they kind of did their own
thing you know they reinterpreted him in
interesting ways and there's even right
now like kind of a boom
in some uh areas of analytic philosophy
and looking at hegel
the pittsburgh uh people you know the
most famous of which i think is robert
brandom who has a new book on
on hegel out you know um which focuses a
lot on the um reconciliation part you
know
how do we how do we get together as a
community
so there's there's all different ways to
make sense of this guy and he's laid a
huge stamp on
history as a result
in ways that we often don't quite
realize and i should mention one other
person
do you remember
this is
you you would have been too young to to
remember this because it would have
happened like i think
perhaps not even in your childhood but
you might remember
this talk after um
the soviet union collapsed
about the end of history
you know
there's this guy francis fukiyama who
was a young guy back then
who wrote a book which was originally
his dissertation called the end of
history and the last man
and he was saying look um the you know
in general hegel was right about one
thing we go through these
transformations of history hegel wasn't
right about history being done in his
time but with the fall of the soviet
union and the collapse of international
communism as a
alternative way of thinking and living
to
western liberal democracies and
capitalism
it looks like they've they've won
you know the the us and europe and
australia and japan
that's it they're the end of history
and you know there of course there could
be some authoritarian places like
singapore
you know where it works for a while but
it's not going to keep working and the
islamic world you know there's some
things happening there but they're not
going to really change history
and i think that was i mean that was the
late 90s
and then uh
you know
a lot of people were like yeah i don't
think this is really true but a lot of
people bought into it and they're like
yeah
we're done
um liberal democracy capitalism
rule of law that is the final state for
human beings we we finished it oh isn't
it wonderful to be at the end of history
then 9 11 happened the war on terror and
you know uh i think people are now quite
aware that we're we're not at the end of
history
but you know
these sort of things uh he was basing it
on hegel
an interpretation of hegel
fukuyama to his credit
has you know at many points said yes i
was wrong about this and there's more
happening now
he didn't just like stick to it and try
to
pretend that nothing that you know none
of this other stuff is history i mean
think about what it would have been like
to be a right hegelian and claim
yeah all this other stuff that we see
happening in front of our eyes
hegel didn't talk about it but it's not
really it's not really happening we're
just gonna like
fix everything up and have a wonderful
state that we all can can live in and
you know it takes a certain kind of
blindness to to do that right
but i mean we could be subject to
blindness
too right
so
any other
before they kick us out yeah one more
you you uh you focus on and i think it
was his first book yeah the
phenomenology yeah what are the others
encyclopedia afterwards
i guess i'm wondering you know the
encyclopedia i think was more
comprehensive if i understood that right
and and wouldn't be as more mature
yeah i think
so why did people seem to focus so much
on his first earlier work which was more
i guess limited his encyclopedia
that is the million-dollar question
right so
if you're going to like read them in
order
first you got to get through this book
and that's hard enough right
and it doesn't have to be quite as hard
as hegel made it but he did make it much
more difficult than it needs to be
and then there's the science of logic
and that is even more abstract
and more difficult to work through and
there's more of it
right and then there's the encyclopedia
logic which is is an easier read and
does talk i mean some of the ground it
goes over is the same stuff as in the
phenomenology some of it is is
additional things and you're right
there's a there's a maturity that's
developing and then we have this this
last
published work the philosophy of write
which is very very interesting in its
own right and does get read
quite a bit by people who are interested
in political and legal theory
or if they're like hegelians you know
but there's not a lot of hegelians out
there
so i think the answer to it is
it's so much work to get through this
this one that a lot of people just stop
there
you know and it's not quite clear how
the hell is this this you know some
people are like well this is the
introduction to the logic and then you
read the logic and like
how the hell do these things map on to
each other you know how do they hook up
it doesn't it's not as simple as it's
being
presented
i know very few people who've actually
read through the entire science of logic
i've only done it once
in the
25 years i've been reading hegel
because it's a real slog
[Music]
but philosophy of right i think is
getting more and more attention
um
and rightly so there's that that's an
interesting work
and that is his most mature work
but i also think these lectures are a
great resource you know like if you if
you look at the religion section here
it's it's a long section
but it's it's not that um
extensive and a lot of the treatments of
religions in it
are frankly not very good you know
um so like it's it's about
this much of the book right he's got
lectures on the philosophy of religion
that go way into more detail sometimes
still get things wrong um but are at
least you know
trying to do a better job and those are
those are in some respect more mature
right because they're coming later in
his career and so
um
we can take those as providing a fuller
conception of what's what's happening so
we should probably we should probably
wrap up
you